the division story takes us through a
whirlwind of events that stems from the
outbreak of a lethal virus on a major
city and now the government and general
population reacted to this situation
control over the city is lost and the
area turns into a lawless sermon run by
the optimizing of multiple hostile
factions sounds like a good movie right
but what about the civilians on the
front line is stuck fighting for
survival trying to keep out of sight
while scavenging for food and water no
wonder so many of them have picked up
whatever weapons they can find and
grouped up with people in the same
situation just to be able to feed their
families all support from outside of the
city seems to be lost there alone
desperate and doing the best they can
given the current situation within all
of the mayhem as the world forgotten
about them the fact that this is now
spread to the rest of the world it's
likely that this is indeed the case but
there is one voice a voice for the
people a voice that refuses to be
ignored Ritva Lessie welcome back i'm
rick for lassie and you you lucky
bastards are listening to wouldn't you
know it and if you listenin that means
you really are lucky bastard you
apparently won the genetic lottery and
can't catch the green poison like 95% of
the rest of humanity rick Valecia is a
freelance reporter and radio show
broadcaster his radio show can be heard
all over the city on the radios of the
safe houses and the base of operations
born and raised in New York City he uses
personal pirate radio show called
wouldn't you know it to talk about the
current issues rumors and theories
regarding the situation at hand the
lessees reports cover a range of topics
like the green poison details about the
various factions around the city the
dark zone and directive 51 an admitted
conspiracy theorist with a paranoid
streak most of his reporting is based on
either firsthand observations or the
information from the sources he is
genuinely concerned for the city and his
fellow New Yorkers continually urging
his listeners to stay safe and keep the
viii fallacy has taken the role of the
voice of the city making it his priority
to keep everyone informed of the going
ons around New York City throughout the
main storyline Valecia is constantly up
to date with everything happening in the
city he's super supportive of the JTF
and everything they do but understands
like any resource at this time we don't
have enough of them he goes on over a
series of broadcasts to talk about bliss
in the last man battalion and their
plans to take over the streets of
Manhattan but also to warn people of the
inmates escaping from Rikers Island and
pouring onto the main streets of New
York City Rick also talks of the
cleanest nutjobs covered head-to-toe in
hazmat gear with homemade flamethrowers
he says that there could be simple city
sanitation but he also suspects that the
cleaners the representatives of the DCD
scientists are there clearing the
infection or are they burning up the
evidence the less he talks about the
dark side about how nobody knows exactly
what's there and nobody's saying would
go and to find out so he goes to check
it out with his own eyes he can be seen
interacting you're the leader of the JTF
if the lessee suspects that the
government has sealed off the serie to
hide something and that perhaps it's a
blast zone of a bio weapon but there's
one thing for sure the place terrified
something here over the wall he could
see bodies everywhere on the streets
hanging off the walls bullet holes blast
shadows burned out windows and doors he
said it feels haunted is any conspiracy
theorist would react
lessee doesn't exactly have any
favorable views towards the division and
directive 51 now these people what the
directive refers to as the first wave
why'd they calm the first wave because
they got a second wave embedded right
behind him that's right New York you
thought the fun was over but no you get
a whole new bunch of faceless government
overlords to deal with and the best part
is you don't even
oh they are they could be your neighbor
your coworker your cousin your
brother-in-law your [ __ ] grandmother
for all I know hell you would be one
yourself
and not even know it that's how deep
they're buried sleep with one eye open
New Yorker in one of his final
broadcasters vanilla game philosophy
goes on to tell us that things aren't
much better outside of New York the
world isn't just sitting there waiting
for us to make it through the situation
the epidemic is now global numbers
released on the DC DS website shows that
the infection numbers are continuing to
rise every city in America is under
martial law being enforced by state and
national guards there are food shortages
riots overloaded hospitals and the power
grids are failing so what's my point my
point is you're like me you can turn
yourself the world you know is waiting
for you on the other side of this mess
but here's the thing
what if it's not while he can be a
little intense and can take conspiracy
theories to a whole new level nothing
really seems to be out of place here
he's just a concerned member of the
public being open and honest about his
feelings towards the current situation
it's obvious that he has someone on the
inside
possibly so on in the JTF that's feeding
him some inside information but at this
stage it's nothing that can cause any
harm that is until a little later in the
story we start hearing some new
broadcasts from Phil se and this is
where things start getting a little
strange the lessees broadcasts was
starting to get a little more specific
and the information from the sources
were beyond what the JTF had and even
the division in a couple of cases also
were introduced to a new character
Judy Walters through a series of videos
we find out that velocity has been
reaching out to alters in an attempt to
ever be a whistleblower for the
pharmaceutical company she works for she
has evidence that they would held
information on the progress towards a
cure for the virus in the final echo of
the series
Judy is hit by a cab in the street and
killed we can see Rick Valesky on the
side of the street talking to a news
editor saying what he just witnessed and
that the story has been lost he then
noticed two USB stick on the street
which is shown in the eCos containing
non disclosed information about the
company he grabs it and tells the person
on the phone that this story isn't over
before walking away on top of us there's
a series of recordings from a Ruth Messi
who's been following the last seat in an
attempt to expose him because in her
eyes things don't line up and that this
Rick fallacy never existed before the
outbreak that he is likely some sort of
smokescreen put in place by the
government my name is Ruth Massey I've
lived in New York for 32 years and
have a question for you who is Rick
velocity I mean we all know who we think
he is he's the loudmouth who keeps
talking on the radio about what he
thinks is going on but it's he really
that or is what he's saying intended as
a distraction to keep us away from the
real truth I think that's what's really
going on here that the lassi is a
mouthpiece for something or someone and
it's his job just about opinions that
hide the truth and I'm gonna prove it
I'm gonna take down Rick velocity just
you watch me but as we get through the
recordings she abruptly cuts off the
search
stating that they were listening and it
could be too late but it's too big much
bigger than she had imagined and the
closer she was getting to him the more
dangerous it was getting I'm giving up
on the velocity story too dangerous you
think bigger than you think
is only the tip of the iceberg they're
gonna kill me maybe they're already
gonna kill me no no maybe this is too
late I'm telling you whatever you do
stay away from Rick Coletti stay away
and as far as the story goes this is the
last we hear of Rick Villa see what
happened to him where is he now what did
he do with the USB stick there's
potentially holding information towards
secure
I believe that Rick Valecia was found by
kena long before relocating to the West
Side pier and that he's been used by
kina to relay information and through
the division of track have you got that
person in your life that can't keep a
secret to save himself have you ever
used this person to perhaps relay some
information to the wider audience that
otherwise wouldn't sound as good coming
directly from the source kina has been
using Valecia as this person
Rick ville se has two attributes that
kina saw as being easy to manipulate to
get him to do what he wanted number one
the lessee is a paranoid conspiracy
theorist who hates the government and
the division into you only anything get
in the way of informing the public of
what exactly is going on he couldn't
just take Velasquez hostage and then
force him to do it because this just
doesn't fit with the lessees character
to just roll over and do what he's told
he'd rather go down as a martyr all
Keena would have to do is feed for lassi
exactly the information that he wants to
hear and exactly what kena wanted to be
made public across Manhattan feeding
into Rick's paranoia against the
government keener explains that he was
once a part of the first wave division
agents and that when things went bad
they abandoned the agents and left them
for dead in the dark zone when things
went from bad to worse that ended all on
him Rick velocity would have bought into
this thinking the keener is actually one
of the good guys
trying to save humanity having left the
division behind in exchange for this
information plessis asked to relay the
specifics of his whereabouts and
possibly even hand over the USB
containing the information about the
duction of a cure now I'm not too sure
about this one as we haven't heard
anything from Vlasic perhaps kina killed
Valecia freak got what wanted from but
what I think is more likely is that kina
didn't inform the Lacey of the location
on the Westside pier until well after
he'd left the island all together in one
of his later broadcasts the less he
mentions kina being spotted in a very
specific location on the Westside pier
because of the recent events the hostile
factions band together ago after kina
and the division follows the factions to
find out what's going on kina obviously
wanted the cell phones and laptop to be
found they were recorded specifically
for the division agents to here possibly
continuing in his attempt to recruit
agents to his course later in another
broadcast Falasca gives a spiel about
how he'd escape the city if you wanted
to it wouldn't be through force but
through the manipulation of an
individual perhaps a weaker or more
disparate individual the spiel is almost
identical to what kina says to us in one
of his last recordings the quarantine as
is setup is good good as keeping idiots
on the island oh sure the coast guards
watching the water and the JTF
guarding the bridges and the tunnels but
the thing is this the weakest component
in any system is people all I takes is
one guy who takes a bribe one optimist
to thinks he's smarter than everyone
else one desperate mother or father
who'll do anything for their kid and the
whole system breaks down and that one
little slip that one tiny crack that's
all I needed then we have Ruth messy
admittedly she sounds absolutely Bechet
crazy but she was so dead set on finding
and exposing Brookville se then it must
mean something pretty big to get her to
suddenly stop pursuing him in her words
the trail was getting too dangerous
maybe kina got to earth
for me this theory answers a lot of the
questions like how did the lessee know
so much about Erin keener
why did he go from having a somewhat
positive outlook on the JTF to just
treating them like another branch of the
government that couldn't be trusted how
is he getting the information before the
JTF and even the division though I admit
there's a few pieces missing but this
feels like the most plausible when
considering the personality and
character traits of these two
individuals what do you think do you
have any ideas of what happened to Rick
fallacy love them all load them there
are certainly more to the story than
what we're seeing on the outside it
feels pretty safe to assume that we'll
be seeing more of Erin keener in the
future but given the new information
that has come across do you think we'll
be seeing rip velocity in the capital
digging deeper into the story of the
green poison now I can't forget to say
thank you to a few of the many amazing
people for being able to go the extra
mile and supporting the channel
especially Devereaux you legend you
thanks again for your continued support
before I go don't forget about the agent
watch giveaway we have going at the
moment I discussed it more in the last
video but I'll add a link to the
competition in the description I'll be
announcing a winner next week Cheers the
green poison where'd it come from some
yuppie scum millennial helicopter mom
refusing to give her kids a goddamn
measles shot I wish I hate those morons
but this ain't measles and that ain't
the way the world works and a named
Ebola or Marburg it didn't involving
batshit some monkey aid before some
idiot ate the monkey no I tell you where
it came from it came from a lab this is
some designer [ __ ] people somebody
cooked this up on purpose and and maybe
got out by accident or maybe they let it
out on purpose but either way if you
don't think the federal government is
involved in some [ __ ] up way or other
than a you don't have my sources and B
you can come with
for the last 60 years because God knows
there ain't no advantage for people who
love power in a situation like this
right nah never happen wakin up New
Yorker open your eyes
think
[Music]